[Musique]
il est né en 1970
on fête les 50 ans avec deux ans de
retard lié aux que vides sauf sans doute
tous
donc c'est un comparateur de musique de
danse et de théâtre il a les trois
disciplines ce qui n'est pas le cas de
tous les conservatoires c'est un
conservatoire communal qui aujourd'hui
regroupe 430 élèves
26 professeurs et deux administratifs
où
nous avons un maximum de disciplines
musicales musicale de danse et d'un
drame
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on a trois concerts avec les professeurs
dont un qui est le gala de clôture de
ses 50 ans qui sera qui se fera au
théâtre les 4 et 5 décembre au théâtre
du vésinet où en plus on a fait venir
des anciens élèves qui sont devenus
professionnels en fait
l'enseignement artistique d'une manière
générale
elle va bien au delà justement d'un
enseignement artistique c'est à dire que
vous avez des élèves
qui sont dans un travail quotidien il ya
une forme d'autonomie en fait on apprend
l'autonomie et la troisième chose qui
pour nous est
assez valorisante en fait c'est
l'intérieur générationnel quand vous
avez un orchestre vous pouvez avoir un
orchestre d'élèves avec des élèves qui
ont huit ans et des élèves qui ont 60
ans à côté il n'y a aucune barrière
d'âge et il ya aucune barrière sociale
quand vous faites de la musique ou quand
vous faites de la danse d'ailleurs c'est
exactement pareil
[Musique]